I feel like if you try to keep up with
what's going on in the industry at all
times is a never-ending rat race and so
I just try to focus on what I'm doing I
have the most fun deliver what I like
making and go from there
my name is Tyler Oakley I am a digital
entrepreneur and I am 27 so I started
making YouTube videos back in 2007 I was
a freshman in college and at the time
nobody was doing it as like a job or as
a way to achieve anything I just kept
making videos talking about my dorm room
or about classes or whatever telling
stories is just like a diary and the
more videos I made the more people
watched and now almost a decade later I
am doing it full-time
[Music]
you
I was not nervous because I didn't think
anybody would watch and I think now if
you start there's a lot of expectations
or pressures of what you should be doing
or how you should make it but back then
I was just doing it because it was fun
YouTube has definitely revolutionised
the entertainment industry in so many
ways but I think the most important way
is giving casting decisions to the
audience themselves where there was used
to be so many barriers of entry to
entertainment now anybody really has an
opportunity to create their own platform
so many people from disenfranchised
communities that might have been
underrepresented in traditional media to
begin with now have opportunities to
reach audiences that are thirsty for
them and for those reasons it's
completely turned Hollywood on attack
the key to success to me is offering to
the world what only you can offer on
YouTube when you first start you might
watch so many people and feel so
inspired and without even thinking about
it emulate some of the things that they
do whether it's and how you present
yourself or in your editing or whatever
but I would always say like why would
anybody subscribe to that when that's
already successful and original
somewhere else so recognizing what only
you can do recognizing what makes your
content you is going to make you
successful people gravitate toward
originality
it's not gonna happen overnight and if
you do go viral with your first video I
would say that's more of a curse than a
blessing because there's so much
expectation of what you then have to
keep doing I would much rather have a
very slow build which is exactly what I
had to slowly grow a community and to
deliver what you want to make as opposed
to what people expect
[Music]